[Applause]
what do we do now
[Applause]
[Music]
i watched that like five times before we
started the show today and i'm gonna
call back to it in just a second because
there's something if you didn't see it
there's something even better than joe
biden not knowing where he's going or
what he's doing which is just obvious
and an everyday occurrence at this point
uh i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message today is april 5th
2022 and uh let's call back that because
it's not just that joe biden doesn't
know where he's going or what he's doing
that's standard but i like when he turns
to pete look at this he tells me where
do i go what do i do what am i doing
what do i do pete i don't know i'm just
gay pete i don't know i got to travel
something i don't know which way you're
supposed to walk how am i supposed to do
i'll go that way you go this way
these people are such inept clowns they
literally don't know which way to walk
at the end of a talk and the president
is looking at people who are completely
unqualified to do anything you would
think that the transportation secretary
at the very least would know which way
to walk at the end of a speech i'm the
transportation secretary i'm gay pete
walk this way
god i hate these people anywho uh i got
a book coming out uh it's called don't
burn this country and it comes out on
april 12th and uh you should buy it
because it's really good i promise you
that it's really good you can either buy
the the physical copy of course or the
audiobook is great i read it myself uh
it comes out in one week from today
that's right tuesday april 12th in the
year of 2022 daverubin.com
book and then as you know i'm heading
out on tour all over the place we launch
in florida i've got special guests on on
most of the shows we're still figuring
out orlando the big the big first show
uh but after that don junior is going to
be joining me in west palm beach bennie
johnson in clearwater andrew clavin in
raleigh north carolina michael mallis in
atlanta janmi park in chicago glenn back
in dallas megan mccain in d.c megan
kelly in west nyack dennis prager and
braille larry elder and oxnard douglas
murray in san jose blake masters in
phoenix brian callan in denver we just
added that one yesterday you can get
tickets right now at daverubin.com
events tickets are going fast we just
added a bunch more vips because they
sold out at most of the shows real quick
so i think we added 20 more yesterday at
each specific venue so you can check
that out daverubin.com
[Music]
events all right so what are we going to
talk about today you know i've been
trying to do these narrative shows
lately where we sort of go through over
the course of a half hour what is going
on in the world
why are these people lying about
everything let's see what they're lying
about how do we expose the lies and then
and then really what i'm focused on more
than anything else is how do we fight
back and how do we fight back how do we
build new things how do we ignore them
get away from them disconnect from them
well there are some signs that we can do
those things and uh and that's really
where i want to put most of my energy
the big thing over the last couple weeks
obviously has been this nonsensical
don't say gay
bill here in florida as you know the
word gay is not in the bill and they
could have just as easily if the media
cared about any truth they could have
just as easily called it the don't say
straight bill because the point is that
you can't talk about sex and gender
identity with kindergartners through
third graders which everyone in their
right freaking mind knows is proper and
right and all of that stuff okay so they
could have called it don't say straight
but the media lies about everything it's
bill
hb1557 but they they love a meme and
then they get their nonsensical blue
check journalists and they're sort of
brain damaged hollywood celebrities to
you know run with don't say gay and all
that good stuff well ron desantis is
just continuing to fight back so he has
signed the bill so the bill exists the
bill exists and all the bill is stopping
teachers from doing is telling second
graders that they can have private
meetings with teachers where they can
tell boys that they're girls and girls
that they're boys and that they could
then hide that from the parents we all
know we all know that's right that's
right and it shouldn't be done and they
keep telling us oh that's not being done
well we've got some evidence that it
actually is being done in schools
throughout the nation uh but desantis
just is not taking it lying down he is
just fighting back against basically the
biggest wokest
mouse run corporation in the world my
view is is yeah we should just treat
everybody equally
we shouldn't let one company have their
own set of rules compared to everybody
else and i think they've been able to
sustain this because they've had a lot
of clout
for many many decades and i think now
with seeing kind of what's happening
it's not just opposing a bill i think
it's it's demagoguing the bill but then
also these videos with these people out
in california who are working very high
up in this company the stuff coming out
of their mouths is unbelievable that
they view their programming as a way to
inject a lot of these topics into
programming for very young kids and i
think i can tell you as a parent of
young kids that is not what i want to be
seeing them talking about pushing an
agenda an ideological agenda okay so i
think there's a whole host of stuff but
it's really going to be up for the
legislature
okay so that's a guy just saying a bunch
of honest stuff and it's direct and it's
clear and it's obvious and as i said
everyone that doesn't have brain damage
agrees with it now if you think if
you're still watching the dave rubin
program and you think that ron desantis
is a liar and that it can't be true that
disney would be intentionally
putting these messages in to stories
with young kids to intentionally confuse
these kids etc etc for whatever their
end means are well why don't you take it
from the director and writer of proud
family on disney
this was a leaked disney internal video
this is latoya avenue the director and
writer of proud family it's a children's
movie and she obviously has other
influence
throughout disney saying that that is
actually exactly what
she does when it comes to inserting
these messages our leadership over there
has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda and so let's have
these two characters kiss let's in the
background like i was just wherever i
could just basically adding queerness to
like no one would stop me and no one was
trying to stop me
okay in case
you've missed it
i'm okay with gay people
i'm married to a gay person i woke up
this morning there was a gay dude next
to me okay
i'm cool with that
we're having kids
i have gay friends
across the political spectrum
well not as many anymore but i've got
some gay friends too lesbians
lesbians i'm friends with okay
i know a lot of gay people and gay
people want nothing to do with this
thing i know the meme out there is that
the lgbt community wants this and this
is such an affront to young gay people
and everything else but this is absolute
complete nonsense this is about state
ownership of your children
more than anything else that's what this
is about do you think ultimately that
your children's
values and thoughts
are property of the state or do you
believe that parents are allowed to
teach
children whatever it is that they want
in terms of values and family and all of
those things and the state should maybe
teach math i don't know math history
stuff like that science little science
maybe some music that would be nice um
but they shouldn't be allowed to
secretly indoctrinate children
and confuse children we're talking about
k through three really again i know i
keep doing this but i want you to think
about a six or seven year old that's in
your life almost everyone watching this
you have a niece or a nephew or a
daughter or a cousin or something
a six-year-old that you would want to
start talking to them about sex is
insane insane and again this has nothing
to do with being gay a straight teacher
you wouldn't want a straight teacher to
be telling the six-year-old about
straightness either they'd be going
crazy actually the lefty whack jobs and
the woksters would all be going nuts if
this was a straight teacher that was
secretly meeting with a possibly gay kid
to not talk about you know to talk about
how they should be straight right but
they're okay with it when it's a teacher
talking about being gay anyway this
story continues into a litany of lunacy
because now new york city which was once
the greatest
city in the world the city where i spent
most of my formative years before i
moved to los angeles okay uh it has now
been completely destroyed by the left
and and the workstars and everything
else but now they're inviting all the
gay people because they think gay people
are fleeing florida but before i get to
that real quick i want to talk to you
guys about raycon you know did you make
a new year's resolution this year if you
did more power to you but if not that
doesn't mean you shouldn't still find a
way to shake things up whether it's by
switching up your workout routine or
going someplace new whatever way you
challenge yourself this new year there's
no better way to do it than with a pair
of raycon wireless earbuds in your ears
raycon wireless earbuds
excuse me are the best way to bring you
uh bring audio with you because no
matter how much you shake things up
literally no matter how much you shake
you know they won't fall out of your
ears the everyday earbuds look feel and
sound better than ever there's also
awareness mode for when you need to
listen to your surroundings so that you
can stay safe when you're on the go with
optimized gel tips for the perfect
in-ear fit these earbuds are so
comfortable and they will not budge
trust me
raycon offers eight hours of playtime
and a 32-hour battery life you get
quality audio at half the price of other
premium audio brands it's no wonder that
raycon's earbuds have over forty eight
thousand five star reviews and right now
my listeners can get fifteen percent off
their recon order at buy raycon dot com
slash reuben that's by raycon dot com
slash reuben buy raycon dot com slash
reuben
back to me all right so now let's
juxtapose some sanity in florida the
governor
fighting the insanity of new york city
which is the whole damn thing but let's
focus
on eric adams who is the new
mayor of new york city the new democrat
mayor now remember they had a true
socialist for a couple years in new york
city they had bill de blasio who was in
my opinion just a complete
communist socialist lunatic he destroyed
new york city
many many people have fled new york city
crime is out of control prices are out
of control we'll get to all that in just
a moment but what happened was when he
went out people said ah now we've got
eric adams and he'll be better about
this woke nonsense he'll be better about
policing
and i think he proved my theory that
there are no sane democrats left here is
new york city mayor eric adams that's
what this movement of don't say gay is
about
this political
showmanship
of attempting to demonize a particular
group or community is unacceptable
and we are going to loudly
show our support and say to those who
are living in florida listen we want you
here in new york
you know we want you right here in new
york city and it's more than just saying
that it's also standing up and aligning
ourselves with the men and women of the
lgbtq plus community and stating that we
are in unisons with you and your right
to
have
self-identification your right to be
live the lifestyle and live
the lives that you choose to live
without any form of harassment
yes everything that you just said there
eric adams was pure bunk you made up
what the bill is about you use the name
that is not actually the name and then
you pretended to say a bunch of things
that are completely nonsensical relative
to what's going on here in florida
literally today is tuesday four days ago
i gave a big talk in west palm beach at
the prageru gala i said hello and
introduced ron desantis brought him on
stage with dennis prager when he said
hello to me we shook hands he said dave
how are you i immediately turned to
david i said governor i want you to meet
my husband david he said hi to him we
took a big picture we were waiting on
the pictures it was with the official
photographer he said congratulations on
the kids this guy is not coming for
anyone's rights he's not coming for
anyone's marriage or anything else this
is about indoctrinating children so
everything eric adams said there is a
lie now what's interesting is the guy
that was standing behind eric adams over
his shoulder i'm not even sure who he is
he's someone in the administration but
he then
uh basically took the microphone and he
said you know i know the mayor won't say
it but f ron desantis now that video was
posted on twitter and went viral
yesterday and then you're not going to
believe this guys because we wanted to
show it to you today uh it was uh the
account was suspended there was a count
by the name of mega jew okay and all he
did was post a public press conference
on twitter the clip of a public press
conference and he got banned by
twitter so that's the state of free
speech and our ability to communicate
honestly but okay so here we go so now
the new york city mayor is absolutely
lying without question 100
lock sealed done lying about what's
going on here in florida and he's trying
to capitalize on it how is he doing it
well he tweeted this out with a big gay
picture
new york city's mayor's office breaking
new york city mayor announces a new
digital billboard campaign in five five
florida markets denouncing the hateful
don't say gay law and inviting
floridians to move to new york okay
first off let me be clear about
something you'd have to be a complete
effing [ __ ] to move to new york city
right now that's what you'd have to be i
think i'm being clear
about uh my feelings on that but we
should compare and contrast what's going
on in florida new york now first off
people keep saying this is the big one
from the media there are no schools that
are teaching any of this stuff they're
not indoctrinating these young kids in
elementary school uh with all of this
transgender stuff and that they can cut
off their genitals and be another gender
and all these things these things aren't
happening oh
image
yeah this is from libs of tick tock they
do a great job over there this is a
middle school in new york city it's
called the gateway school and there is a
young girl i assume it's a girl maybe
it's a boy a boy girl i don't know girl
boy uh who uh is giving some sort of
presentation related to all of the flags
of the lgbt community you've got the gay
flag and the trans flag and i don't know
what else is up there i can't even see
it from where i'm sitting but i you know
oh there's the asexual flag what's the
what's the flag with the uh with the
circle in it
the intersex flag what the hell give me
the camera what does this have to do
with education
what does being pansexual what does that
even mean you have sex with pans
demisexual
apache helicopter sexual what do any of
these things have to do with just two
plus two is four
a squared plus b squared is c squared
what is going on here this is all such
manipulated crapola but anyway
people say that's not really happening
they say it's not happening it obviously
is happening it's all over the place and
we've got some more evidence on that
we'll show you just a second but if you
are gay
and you live in florida and you're being
hunted down
you know desantis is out there and he's
got gators and they're on a leash and
he's running around looking for the gays
and oh my god they're listening to dance
music in that house get them
if you're freaking out
and you're going but but eric adams
seems like a nice guy and he wants me
in new york city i should go to new york
city well i would at least at the very
least do your due diligence on what's
going on in new york city because we've
got some info about the crime situation
in new york city
here you go this is from spectrum news
one overall crime in new york city was
up 38.5
last month compared with january 2021
nypd numbers show according to the nypd
increases in crime were seen nearly
across the board
shooting incidents rose 31.6 from 76 in
january of 2021 to 100 last month
transit crime incidents rose 75
from 113 to 198 rape rose uh 26.7
from 101 in january of 21 to 128 last
month robbery rose 33 from 940 to
1251 felony assault rose 12.3 percent
from 1546 to 1736 burglary that's up 7.5
percent from about 1100 to 1189
grand larceny up 58.5 from
2559 to over 4 000 and grand larceny
auto is up 91.5
from 620 to 1187
so gays if the freedom is freaking you
out
and you're scared about desantis and his
henchmen and all of that stuff that is
completely imaginary but they got you
they got you you they just you're a blue
a
non-npc
brainwashed fool you should go to new
york city but know what you're walking
into where you'll most likely be raped
or murdered
or have your car stolen potentially all
at once in which case then you're
allowed to jump the turnstile if you
don't have a car anymore and you want to
get on the subway because they won't
arrest you for that um
now interestingly you know what i like
to do on this program i like to show you
stats from one state and then compare it
to another state now what's happening
here in florida sure again once again
and i don't want to diminish the fact
that desantis is out there with the
gators hunting down the gays the whole
thing but here's some stats on crime in
florida from 98 to 2018 florida
experienced a significant decrease in
both the number and rate of reported
total index crimes the rate is
calculated per 100 000 population
florida's population increased 39
percent during the period violent crime
decreased about 39 percent uh 55 56.6 in
rate and property crime decreased 45.2
percent in number uh 60.6
in rate so crime is going down you see
that's down as you go across the graph
there it's going down uh and these
numbers are continuing under ron
desantis we all know that right we
watched all of these cities burn over
the last two years and why did it not
happen in florida do you think maybe it
happened because we had somebody here
who actually supported law enforcement
and people actually believe in rule of
law and all of that stuff but okay let's
say again you're freaking out you're gay
desantis is trying to get you eric adams
wants you you're like you know what it's
okay it's so i'm freaking out over the
gay thing and it's all right maybe i'm
gonna get murdered maybe my car will get
stolen i'll be raped all of that stuff
i'm still willing to risk it because you
know life will be better there i'll have
more money in my pocket let's say
because it's new york you know the
engine of the world well we've got some
info from nerd wallet uh new york state
income tax rates are four percent four
and a half percent
point
5.25
5.9
six point three three six point eight
five nine point six five ten point three
and max out at ten point nine percent
and then i love this one new york city
and yonkers have their own local income
tax on top of the state tax new york
city income tax rates are
3.078 37262
3819 and 3.876 so that means if you live
in new york city or yonkers you're
paying federal you're paying state
you're paying then the city tax on top
of that they're taking all your money
well
but that must be something similar
there's got to be something similar to
that happening in florida
oh right there's no personal income tax
here in florida zippo
not white supremacy just a zero uh but
okay so let's say you're like you know
what i don't care
sure
i might get raped there i might get
killed they might steal my car
and i'm gonna have to pay all this more
money at least the houses at least the
houses in new york city must be cheaper
than florida because florida's got all
that water people like to live on the
water that must be very expensive we've
got to go to new york to save money if
we escape the rape and the murder and
the crime and the
house prices let's look at some house
prices new york the average price of a
house 750 000 basically florida
480.
that's a bit of a difference i don't
have my calculator here but it's over
two hundred thousand dollars i'll tell
you that much um so the choice is yours
gays
the choice is yours
frankly at this point i don't care about
your sexuality but if you are a lefty
whack job living in the freest state in
the union leave
leave
i got cash here now what my plan was can
i would this be unethical at this point
my plan with the cash was that i was
going to give all this cash to bring
someone save someone from this dystopian
nightmare of california and bring them
here to florida but actually i think
maybe we should switch this i don't know
maybe i'll have to do two jars where i'm
just gonna give cash if you're a lefty
leave
charlie crist get the hell out of here
this nicky freed all you whack jobs you
have everything it's all here the future
of america is here and you freaks
and liars
don't like it just
okay well speaking of high crime high
taxes insane sexual politics woke-ism
ruining the system let's talk about
what's going over on at the uh the white
house uh because there is this gensake
woman she is the press secretary who
will soon have a job on msnbc because
the swamp protects its own and she was
asked about bill hb1557
by fox news's peter ducey what about
this new law in florida at what age does
the white house think that students
should be taught about sexual
orientation and gender identity
well i would say uh first of all peter
we have spoken to
the don't say gay bill in the past i
believe is what you're referring to and
made clear that
as we look at this
this
this law
what we think it's a reflection of is
politicians in florida propagating
misinformed hateful policies that do
absolutely nothing to address
the real issues i would note that
parents across the country are looking
to
you know
national state and district leaders to
support our nation's students to ensure
that kids are treated equally in schools
and that is certainly not this is not a
reflection of that
he's a liar
there's nothing else i need a punching
bag in the show can we get a punching
bag in the studio and for now on every
time i'm going to curse i'm not kidding
i'm just going to punch can we get a
jen's socky punching bag i want her
clown depressed face right next to me
i'm not kidding we're gonna have to
custom this i don't know where you get
one can we go to custom punchingbags.net
or whatever and i want her face right
here and every time we show a clip of
her instead of because what's the point
what's the point of me constantly
commenting on her she's lying again
everything she said was made up instead
i would just punch the clown i'm not
kidding that's what we're gonna have to
do
i know you can't hit a woman you can't
hit a woman well i'll just say she's a
man that's how we're gonna have to do it
anyway she just lies everything she said
there was a lie this has nothing to do
with hate and notice she won't answer
the question the question was very clear
ducey's question was very clear what age
do you think teaching this stuff is
appropriate and she doesn't she
immediately calls it don't say gay and
she won't give an answer um here's more
from saki so if you guys oppose this law
that
bans classroom instruction about sexual
orientation and gender identity in k
through 3.
does white house support that kind of
classroom instruction before
kindergarten do you have examples of
schools in florida that are teaching
kindergarteners about sex education
good question jen are they teaching this
stuff to kids in school she specifically
says kindergartners but obviously what
we're talking about are they teaching
this to young kids in school well you're
not going to believe this one sake
in september of 2020 my daughter told me
after school she had a meeting with
school officials that was held behind
closed doors where they asked her which
restroom she wanted to use
i immediately contacted the school as
told by the guidance counselor and
assistant principal that i could not be
given any information regarding the
meeting and that by law my daughter had
to be the one to authorize my
notification of the meeting or
attendance to the meeting
in other words school officials asked my
13 year old child
her permission as to whether or not my
parental rights would be honored
after many weeks of going back and forth
with the district we learned the middle
school had created a transgender gender
non-conforming support plan with our 13
year old daughter without our knowledge
or consent
the plan was a six page document
completed with my daughter behind closed
doors with three school officials that
included the guidance counselor the
assistant principal and a social worker
i had never met
during the meeting they asked her
questions that could have significantly
impacted her safety and her physical and
emotional well-being such as which
restroom she preferred to use and which
sex she preferred to room with on
overnight field trips
the plan also directed school staff to
use my daughter's birth name when
speaking to us her parents and to use a
different name in school with teachers
staff and students
this plan directed school staff to
conceal from us that this meeting and
plan had ever taken place
okay so joking and goodness aside for a
second
the question really is
do you think that woman
is
a bad person
do you think she's a bigot or hateful or
anything like that or do you think that
she really
actually only cares about the welfare of
her child
and that she should ultimately
be the arbiter of the decisions related
to a young child that let's say her
child is having some gender identity
stuff or maybe thinks that they're gay
or whatever else and by the way there
are all sorts of phases in life and
there are people that detransition as
adults that's something that the
mainstream media won't show you
um obviously because it doesn't fit the
narrative but you know there are kids
that are in sixth grade that think that
they're bi or gay that end up not being
and then there are there are married
adults who are have two kids that
finally come to grips with their
sexuality when they're 55 and it's too
late and then they've brought all sorts
of destruction on their family and
friends and all sorts of other things
but if you watch that video if you think
that that mother
is saying what she's saying because of
hatred or bigotry or any of the pure bs
nonsense that the media and the white
house and the mayor of new york city and
the rest of these people are spewing
you're very just confused you're just
very
confused about the issue they want
parental rights dissolved they want your
children to be property of the state and
many people are willfully letting them
do it now
let's recap the show so far so we've got
desantis he's out there with the
alligators hunting down the gay people
then you've got the mayor of new york
city and despite the murder and the rape
and the crime and all that stuff and the
high house prices and the disastrous
economy he's saying gays come here we'll
take you gays we'll save you from scary
alligator man ron desantis then we
showed you how the white house lies and
obfuscates the truth related to all that
but at least i was going dave you got to
find me a silver lining here thank god
we have cnn right because these people
wouldn't lie to us they wouldn't frame
the issue completely dishonestly and
confuse things and conflate things and
push an agenda that's not what they
would do on cnn
there is an ugly history in the united
states of portraying gays lesbians
transgender people
as perverts as predators who are preying
on children
and when i see some of the coverage in
the last week
seems to me they are just repeating an
ugly history
good morning brian yeah it's it's
exasperating to watch all this go down i
can't believe that it's 2022
and we're still seeing lgbtq families be
framed as predatory or as
diversive or
i would say as
almost almost perverted i mean that
seems to be the message to millions of
lgbtq families by the actions of
governor desantis right now and i
it's heartbreaking to watch because
these are families who already struggle
to get by day to day in the public
square and now have their own government
going after them just for existing when
i'm watching the fox coverage this week
i'm thinking they know what they're
doing like this is something that's very
compelling and scary to their audience
well brian you're right it's it's
brilliant framing because you can't
argue with a parent's right to influence
their child parents care deeply about
their children i'm a parent i get it and
when you focus on this particular subset
kindergarten through third grade again
it's very smart and it's strategic
because most parents will say well yeah
i guess that makes sense it seems pretty
common sense that we wouldn't be talking
about sex or sexual orientation but it
it sort of hides the uh the real
intention behind the bill and the thing
about parental rights framing is that
this is not the first time we've seen
this in american history if you frame uh
you know critical race theory against
parental rights then people feel okay we
have a right to be upset if you think
about go back to segregation
there was a parental rights argument
about we shouldn't really be integrating
and having our kids you know in schools
based on race because that will
introduce another level of intimacy or
relationship and so when you go at that
personal angle you will actually get a
lot of people who miss the sort of
bigger picture behind
what what this bill is really about and
it has a chilling effect
okay so the reason i wanted to show you
that is because that woman almost got it
right she almost got it right that this
stuff makes sense it makes sense you
would not want your kids to be taught
gender theory when they're first graders
and then have that hidden from the
parents it makes sense you would not
want them being taught critical race
theory in school and that have that
hidden from the parents then she tries
to link it somehow to slavery and racism
and all of those other things it's
nonsense it's nonsense they want your
kids i'm not even saying it's because
they're grooming them because they're
pedophiles or whatever the hell everyone
else is saying i'm just saying they just
want to break children and they want to
break the family i think that's pretty
obvious and let's not forget the black
lives matter website when this whole
thing all started all this crazy woke
nonsense started over the last couple
years used to have a section in it
talking about destroying the nuclear
family these things are all connected so
they almost kind of got it right on cnn
but then at the end she but you know
parents really shouldn't have to do
something with that because it's really
kind of hide in bigotry or something
well i want to show you the two the two
chirons that they had here uh now this
first one here focus on parental rights
chips away at gay rights so let's just
pretend you're the average cnn viewer
and you're obviously not that bright you
don't really know what's going on and
you just regurgitate talking points and
all of that one more time throw it up
you would see that you'd flip on cnn
right and no one's really paying
attention to cnn but you flip it on and
you go my god parental rights are
chipping away at gay rights now that has
nothing to do
with this bill there is no one coming
for gay rights in florida do you think
that if ron desantis
and the other right-wing maniacs of
florida were saying we're going to jail
gays we are not going to let gay people
get married we are not going to let gay
people have certain jobs we are not
going to let gay people have kids we're
not going to let gay people buy property
anything that would actually make gay
people unequal under the law you think i
might say something about it i assure
you that i would i assure you that i
would this is about indoctrinating
children
from state employees and then hiding
that from the parents so that that
chiron is an absolute lie and by the way
throw it up one more time you see how
they're they're contrasting these things
so that they're they're trying to train
you
to think that parental rights are bad or
that parental rights are in conflict
with gay rights which is insane gay
rights
used to just be about equality the gays
of stonewall
i know this is i can't wait till the
media matters hit piece on this one the
gays of stonewall would be horrified by
what's going on right now they were
fighting for equality they were fighting
to be equal under the law they were not
fighting for all of this other nonsense
that really is the truth okay it really
is those people who were being arrested
because they were going to bars and as
consenting adults meeting other people
and trying to be in equal relationships
that's what it was about it had nothing
to do with any of this so the media is
now trying they're trying to show you
that parental rights are scary and in
conflict with the thing that you better
worship the most which are gay rights
and by the way we have gay rights it's
equal we're good let's go to the other
chiron for a second the lgbt community
latest to be caught in the culture now
first off look at these two people i
just want to be clear i i have nothing
to do with either one of these dudes and
i mean that as a
as a newscaster or whatever i am or as a
supposed member of the lgbt community um
but the lgbt community latest to be
caught in culture war they brought the
culture war to us
the gay thing was basically over
and this is why you twisted mother
the gay thing was over donald trump in
2016 was on stage before
becoming president with a rainbow flag
saying he did not care who you marry
saying that he didn't care about trans
bathrooms because he's a builder and if
he was building a hotel and you told him
he only had to build one bathroom he
would be thrilled because it would save
him money peter thiel
an openly gay man spoke at the rnc
convention where they nominated donald
trump and said he is a proud gay man and
got a standing ovation
standing ovation i've discussed that
with him privately many times he was
shocked he did not know what was going
to happen when that happened and he got
a standing ovation okay
this thing was done it doesn't mean that
every conservative has to agree with gay
marriage and it doesn't mean that we
have to trample on your religious
liberty and all of those things but this
[ __ ] was over and these people are
dragging it back in because this has
nothing to do with equality anymore this
is about breaking kids this is making
sixth graders look at pansexual flags
and teaching uh you know as the uh as
that mother was talking about that you
can call the kid one name at school but
but hide that from the parents at home
this is absolute crazy nonsense one more
time on that chiron please uh lgbt
community i want to address one other
thing uh my friend douglas murray who's
been on the show many times and we have
an interview coming out with him i think
next week or so uh he's just he's just
one of the clearest thinkers british
conservative thinker if you don't know
him he happens to be gail so he's one of
my best friends he is a good decent man
and he is he is an absolutely brilliant
writer in his last book
the madness of crowds and you should
find my can we link to madness of crowds
in the description on this one let's
make sure we get that in there you
should watch my interview with him
because one of the things that he does
so brilliantly is he separates lgb from
tea in the chapters when he's talking
about this war on sanity and what the
madness of crowds really is all about
because the gay community got there in
terms of equality the gay community got
there just like the the black community
got there just like women got there all
of the just fights for equality you got
to equality and the machine then the
activists said no equality's not enough
we want equity we want to take everybody
down with us we don't want to build
everybody up which is what america and
capitalism and freedom is all about okay
um so douglas in in his brilliant book
madness of crowds he actually separates
them from chapters because he says
actually the lgb thing has nothing to do
with the trans thing and that really is
the truth i don't mean i actually don't
mean this in judgment of any trans
person and as i often say on the show
however you wish to live as an adult is
completely fine with me that that's your
choice right like i know there's some
people not thrilled with my life choices
and i'm not thrilled with other people's
life choices that's completely fine with
me
but pushing this stuff on everybody and
how it's rampaging through all of our
institutions and our television shows
and the media and big tech and all this
stuff it's not authentic it's not real
this is manufactured nonsense for some
other purpose what that is is for
perhaps another show but you know
there's a great quote by thomas soule on
this uh which he said years ago bigotry
is not dead
it's on life support and ain't that the
truth these people needed chris rock in
one of his hbo specials from about 20
years ago the cops need a certain amount
of crime these people need the belief in
bigotry and hatred they have nothing
else what in the world would any of
these leftists or woesters or democrats
have other than thinking that
everybody's out to get them other than
thinking that this thing is evil and
everything else the best freaking
society of all time and that's endless
endlessly what they're pushing on us um
so
fired up today uh let's bring it to
something positive about all of this and
by the way this is all couched in
positivity because what's happening in
florida is positive and if there is
going to be a separation of the states
that's what federalism is all about and
i hope that if you're watching this you
live in a state that is somewhat aligned
with your your views but to really couch
this in some positivity uh the big story
as of this morning is that elon musk the
tesla guy the spacex guy the boring
company guy yeah that guy right there uh
the original co-founder co-creator of
paypal along with peter thiel uh
he now is on the board of twitter i
covered it yesterday that he bought a
9.2 state 9.2 stake in twitter we've got
some info here from forbes uh tesla ceo
elon musk has acquired a 9.2 stake in
twitter the social media giant disclosed
in an sec filing on monday a move that
comes weeks after the billionaire
accused twitter of failing to adhere to
free speech principles uh 2.8 billion
2.89 billion that's how much musk's
twitter stocks were worth based on
friday's closing twitter stock price
surged 27 on monday i mean this guy is
such a baller that when he buys
something he spends about three billion
of his own money and then the stock all
rises so then it's as if he spent less
money on it right and the whole point of
of everything that he's been about over
the last i don't know a couple months at
least is that he's trying to fight for
free speech he's been asking is twitter
you know banning people are they
respecting free speech and all of these
things um so now that he is on the board
so now he is the largest stakeholder but
he's not a majority stakeholder right he
doesn't own 51 so he can't just do
whatever he wants to do but he is the
largest stake holder he actually
replaced morgan stanley as the number
one stakeholder in twitter
um he is going to be on the board he
will be able to make decisions he will
be able to ask questions hey why did we
kill that hunter biden story who did
that did we have any uh
contact with the government on that who
who killed that story is that something
that anyone has asked around here uh he
might say hey how did we decide to get
rid of that donald trump guy does anyone
uh know how we made that final decision
or uh babylon b is suspended one of the
biggest satire sites in the united
states they're suspended right now or
how about this one uh that tucker
carlson guy
is suspended right now all he did was
say that there's differences between uh
men and women males and females uh he's
the largest uh cable news talk show
highest rated cable news talk show host
in history of cable news uh should he be
suspended on our platform elon might
start asking these questions hey how
come dave rubin was suspended in july
for saying that vaccine mandates might
be coming from the federal government
because he ended up being right about
that why'd we suspend him on that one
elon you got your work cut out for you
man but if anyone's up to it it's you so
the point is that that there is some
goodness here there there is some
goodness because good people have to
enter the fight uh this is what i've
been to this is why i started locals
good people have to enter fight build a
better product this is what's going on
over at the daily wire why'd they do
jeremy's razors it's like okay harry's
razors you want to go woke we'll build
our own razor company and sell them and
it sounds like they're already bigger
than harry's razors this is why you
build alternative networks like the
blaze this is why prageru is now doing
prageru kids and daily wires doing daily
wire kids enough of this [ __ ] enough
of this [ __ ] we'll expose it we'll
mock it and then we'll move on so i
don't know that we're quite at the move
on phase but the second we are i will be
the first one to move on i assure you
and i will not talk about any of this
nonsense anymore but we have to somehow
expose it still and mock it as we build
uh for now uh we've got a great uh funny
little uh meme video for you for our
call close today let me run to some
locals comments mad for cars says i want
to be there when elon walks through the
doors for the first board meeting at
twitter well in that case mad for cars
you might want to wait till the cold
close of today's show because we did a
little something for you you're going to
dig it amy says did you hear that a
seattle museum is hosting a drag camp
for 12 to 18 year olds the art of drag i
mean
nothing would surprise me nothing
surprises me at this point if you are an
adult
and you would like to dress like the
opposite gender and put on makeup and do
all of those things and go to a club
blah blah blah then so be it
that's what you're allowed to do why you
feel that you need to push this on
children who are trying to figure out
what the world is in a time of mass
misinformation and confusion that that
does seem a little odd to me uh genie
says i'm a cast iron pansexual i've got
to tell you i love the cast i'm honestly
not sure what pansexual is but i do love
the cast iron and if you want an
incredible recipe for cast iron chicken
parm megan kelly has had it at my house
and said it was the best chicken parm
she's ever had
you can go to davidscookbook.com
that's my david he's a he's an
incredible chef and we've got a cookbook
coming out uh and you can see the recipe
for his cast iron chicken parm a lot of
people say you don't put cheese in a
cast iron but we believe that you can uh
pansexual i'm being told means that
you're down to bang anything
i've enjoyed today's program i hope
you've enjoyed today's program uh we're
extremely busy around here right now
because i've started some of the early
press for dumper in this country a lot
of it won't come out till next week
um we're doing my first the exclusive
launch podcast interview we'll be with
ben shapiro next tuesday and then i'm
pretty much on every freaking show you
can think of and i you know i haven't
been doing television appearances
because they also like you to be quiet
so if you've been wondering where i've
been why i haven't been on fox lately or
newsmax or whatever it's because they
like you to kind of go dark for about a
month beforehand but i will be back on
everything trust me you will be sick of
me by the end of the month uh guys
reminder one week from today my next
book comes out don't burn this country
surviving and thriving in our woke
dystopia i mean did i nail it with the
title on this freaking thing or what you
can get the book at daverubin.com
book and the thing is come back to me
for a second the thing is
you know i don't care about the new york
times i genuinely don't it is an evil
newspaper filled with woke activists it
is a propaganda communist rag it is
trash and dishonest drivel that being
said i would like to get on the new york
times bestseller list again to just
expose the [ __ ] i want to sell so
many copies that they have to put me on
there which is what happened last time
they put me much lower on the list than
per sales
but we sold so many they had to put us
on there and i want to do it this time
because you know sales the beauty of
sales is sales are real
book
purchase guy has book that's an actual
number right so they can't fudge the
sale so the new york times even tells
people there's a little asterisk on
there where they tell people our number
our best seller list is not really based
on sales it's our own secret formula uh
to prove this i saw the numbers from
last week because in the publishing
world they can they expose these numbers
right it's not hidden sales numbers are
real that's how people transfer money
and commerce
i think it was last week the new york
times bestseller list they had about six
in the top ten they had about six books
that had sold between like two and four
thousand copies the number 11 book on
the new york times bestseller you're not
going i don't think i told you guys this
the number 11 book last week was glenn
beck's new book and it had sold i think
it was 54 000 copies last week okay it
came out a couple weeks ago but they
just fudged these numbers and anyway i
would love to get on there just to
expose the fudge
i wanna i wanna fudge expose that's what
i wanna do with these people they're
just terrible terrible people uh if you
wanna join me on tour as you know you
can go to daverubin.com slash events if
you get vip tickets i am guaranteeing
the one second hug a selfie and maybe
i'll even sign your book my full
interview with the wolf of wall street
jordan belfort is up on youtube and on
blaze and on rumble etc etc oh and i
have a new interview really interesting
guy david mamet who's a playwright uh
filmmaker glenn gary glenn ross and wag
the dog bunch more uh former leftist who
woke up and yet he still lives in
hollywood so we get into some really
deep stuff clip one is up today and on
that note mad for cars this cold clothes
about the board meeting that's happening
at twitter right now
goes out to you
what do you think of him
he's a pedantic pontificating
pretentious bastard a belligerent old
fart a worthless steaming pile of cow
dung
figuratively speaking
you